Katrina: 这是谁啊
Katrina: Who is this?
Shure: 啊看我笑的多灿烂啊
Shure: Ah, look how brightly I'm smiling
Shure: 啊我又暗淡了
Shure: Ah, now I'm dim again
Shure: 老板知道为什么我暗淡了吗
Shure: Boss, do you know why I'm dim?
Jack: 因为没给钱是吧
Jack: Because you didn't get paid, right?
Shure: 因为我想涨工资
Shure: Because I want a raise
Jack: 啊
Jack: Ah
Shure: 可以了可以了可以了
Shure: That's it, that's it, that's it
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Katrina: 慢点慢点慢点慢点慢点
Katrina: Slow down, slow down, slow down, slow down, slow down
Jake:准时
Jake: On time
Shure: 懂懂
Shure: Got it
Shure: 这叫什么
Shure: What's this called?
Shure: 音乐脱口秀
Shure: Music talk show
Shure: 懂了吧
Shure: Got it?
Jake: 可以
Jake: Okay
Alice:你这状态持续多久了
Alice: How long have you been like this?
Jack: 这是有有病
Jack: This is an illness
Jack: 有病得治
Jack: Illness needs treatment
Shure: 哎
Shure: Sigh
Katrina: 你弹的够悲伤的
Katrina: Your playing is sad enough
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Nicous: 妈的 跟着修硕这节奏
Nicous: Damn, following Shure's rhythm
Shure: 有一种
Shure: There's a kind of
Tasha:哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Shure: 怎么我的诗朗诵不好吗
Shure: What's wrong, is my poetry recitation not good?
Katrina: 特别好都想哭了
Katrina: It's so good, it makes me want to cry
Jack: 太好了
Jack: Too good
男嘉宾:关了
Male Guest: Turn it off.
Shure: 我都不知道难忘今宵的歌词是啥
Shure: I don't even know the lyrics to "Unforgettable Tonight."
Jake:就就这个
Jake: Just this.
Shure: 难忘今宵
Shure: "Unforgettable Tonight."
Shure: 我们大家一起大合唱
Shure: Let's all sing it together.
刘婷:这是你们的固定节目吗
Liu Ting: Is this your regular program?
Jack: 我们来点年头小点的吧
Jack: Let's pick a newer song.
Alice:哈哈是吧
Alice: Haha, right?
Shure: 年头小点的歌
Shure: A newer song.
Shure: 怎么你你哈哈哈
Shure: What's so funny?
Jack: 哎这个可以可以
Jack: Hey, this one works.
Alice:我俩坐那吧
Alice: Let's sit over there.
Jake:难忘哈哈哈
Jake: Unforgettable, haha.
Alice:你把凳子搬过来呗
Alice: Move the chair over here.
Katrina: 他改精神攻击了
Katrina: He's using psychological attacks now.
Jack: 你就会这一句是吧
Jack: You only know this one line, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Jake:不行了不行
Jake: It's not working.
Jake:你还要加工资
Jake: You want a raise?
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Jake:你还要加工资
Jake: You want a raise?
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yes.
Jack: 这应该 是后经也损人位是吧
Jack: This should be a post-event insult, right?
Shure: 大家有有什么想听的歌吗
Shure: Does anyone have a song they want to hear?
Shure: XBZ都会弹
Shure: XBZ can play anything.
Nicous: 我会库吗
Nicous: Can I cook?
Nicous: 哎呀这终于恢复正常了
Nicous: Ah, things are finally back to normal.
Nicous: 来来来找个什么歌唱什么
Nicous: Come on, let's find a song to sing.
Shure: 唱什么
Shure: What to sing?
Shure: 你刚才说什么
Shure: What did you just say?
Shure: 不会
Shure: I don't know.
Jack: 看起来可以唱
Jack: Looks like you can sing it.
女嘉宾:真的很会唱啊
Female Guest: You can really sing!
Jack: 能唱就唱
Jack: If you can sing, then sing.
Shure: 给大家表演一个
Shure: Let me perform for everyone.
Shure: 每次都会在酒后给大家表演的
Shure: I always perform after drinking.
Shure: 叫什么来着哈哈
Shure: What's it called again, haha?
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Alice:本人不伤心
Alice: I'm not sad at all.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Alice:试这个点心
Alice: Try this snack.
Shure: 就四个和弦
Shure: It's just four chords.
Shure: 你往低了点弹不就得了吗
Shure: Can't you play a bit lower?
Shure: 哎呀我都能
Shure: Oh, I can do it.
Shure: 弹到哪了
Shure: Where did I play up to?
Shure: 就1645四个和弦
Shure: Just the 1645 four chords.
Shure: 我我我我我怎么怎么起的啊
Shure: How did I start it?
Shure: 哎怎么怎么卧槽
Shure: Oh, what the heck?
Jack: 我又寡言掉了你懂个叫我行不
Jack: I'm going quiet again, can you call me?
Shure: 我我我我最啊我最爱
Shure: I, I, I love...
Shure: 卧哎卧槽
Shure: Oh, what the heck?
Shure: 哈哈哈等一下
Shure: Hahaha, wait a second.
Alice:气急败坏
Alice: So flustered.
Shure: 啊啊啊找到了
Shure: Ah, found it.
Shure: 谢谢大家谢谢大家
Shure: Thank you, everyone. Thank you.
Alice:你喝酒不喝
Alice: Do you drink?
Alice:我给你拿杯子
Alice: I'll get you a cup.
Shure: 好了我们的egoKTV
Shure: Alright, our egoKTV.
Nicous: 下一首
Nicous: Next song.
Jack:
Jake: 下一首
Jake: Next song.
Shure: 别下一首了哈哈哈
Shure: No more next songs, haha.
Shure: 一会老底都揭没了怎么办
Shure: What if all our secrets are revealed?
Jack: 下一首
Jack: Next song.
Shure: 哎大家大家
Shure: Hey everyone.
Alice:露西
Alice: Lucia.
Shure: 还会唱什么
Shure: What else can you sing?
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:过来点
Shure: 还听过什么
Shure: What else have you heard?
Shure: 就是能大家一起调动氛围一起唱的
Shure: Something that can get everyone singing along.
Lucia:想你了
Lucia: Miss you.
Shure: 想你了
Shure: Miss you.
Lucia:哦不不不
Lucia: Oh no, no.
Shure: 想谁了哈哈哈
Shure: Miss who, haha.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia:人家想我了哈哈
Lucia: Someone misses me, haha.
Shure: 哎呀想想想想
Shure: Oh, oh, oh.
Shure: 别普通朋友了哈哈
Shure: No more just friends, haha.
Shure: 老老在这唱这多晦气是吧哈哈
Shure: Man, singing this here is just bad luck, right? Haha
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What is this?
Shure: 你这什么风格
Shure: What style is this?
Jack: 你今天弹这个
Jack: You're playing this today.
Jack: 应该有很多什么情歌之类的
Jack: Should be a lot of love songs or something.
Jack: 就流沙嘛
Jack: Like quicksand.
Jack: 爱情好像流沙
Jack: Love is like quicksand.
Jack: 不复挣扎嘛
Jack: You can't struggle out of it.
Lucia:出现
Lucia: Appear.
Shure: 我这就
Shure: I'm just...
Lucia:你今天晚上住这边吗
Lucia: Are you staying here tonight?
Shure: 主要已经脱离了那个唱苦情歌的阶段
Shure: Mainly because I've moved past the stage of singing sad love songs.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
男嘉宾:有了对像了是吧
Male Guest: Got someone now, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 那你唱那个
Katrina: Then sing that one.
Jack: 那那那来点甜甜的吧
Jack: Then, then, let's have something sweet.
Katrina: 你唱那个
Katrina: Sing that one.
Katrina: 恋爱ING吧反正你也是恋爱ING
Katrina: How about "In Love"? You're in love anyway.
Shure: 恋爱ING的词是什么来着
Shure: What's the lyrics to "In Love" again?
Shure: 那那有点唱不上去
Shure: That one is a bit hard to sing.
男嘉宾:情非得已
Male Guest: "Unwilling Love."
Alice:咋啦
Alice: What's up?
刘婷:快跟人亲热亲热快点
Liuting: Hurry up and get close to someone, quick.
Katrina: 情非得已也行
Katrina: "Unwilling Love" is fine too.
男嘉宾:有何不可
Male Guest: Why not?
Katrina: 唱素颜吧
Katrina: Sing "Bare-faced."
Alice:我鞋呢
Alice: Where are my shoes?
Katrina: 对着你女朋友唱素颜
Katrina: Sing "Bare-faced" to your girlfriend.
Jake:哎唱素颜了
Jake: Hey, sing "Bare-faced."
Alice:我这人不爱穿鞋有什么毛病
Alice: I just don't like wearing shoes, is that a problem?
Katrina: 你女朋友给你唱那个
Katrina: Your girlfriend will sing to you.
Katrina: 她唱女生不
Katrina: She'll sing the girl's part, right?
男嘉宾:来点那什么小小那个
Male Guest: How about something small?
Alice:我又不脚臭
Alice: It's not like my feet stink.
Shure: 来嘛
Shure: Come on.
Katrina: 素颜嘛
Katrina: "Bare-faced."
Shure: 唱一个素颜来了
Shure: Let's sing "Bare-faced."
Shure: 素颜来了
Shure: "Bare-faced" is coming.
Katrina: 来嘛
Katrina: Come on.
Shure的女友:等会我再喝口
Shure's GF: Wait, let me take another sip.
Alice:我去给他拿杯子
Alice: I'll get him a cup.
Shure: 行
Shure: Alright.
叉叉:素颜 素颜
Jack: No makeup, no makeup.
Shure: 来给我给我也整一杯
Shure: Come on, get me a cup too.
Alice:哎哟
Alice: Oh, okay.
Shure的女友:还有杯子吗
Shure's GF: Are there any more cups?
Alice:来我给你洗一个
Alice: Let me wash one for you.
Alice:哎没了我靠
Alice: Oh no, we're out.
刘婷:用碗也行
Liu Ting: Using a bowl works too.
Alice:好那我就碗了啊
Alice: Okay, I'll use a bowl then.
Shure的女友:这没杯子了吗
Shure's GF: Are there really no more cups?
Alice:这没了
Alice: We're out.
Shure: 你能可以只弹左手
Shure: Can you just play with your left hand?
Shure: 刘帅要不你替我弹
Shure: Choiszt, can you play for me?
Choiszt: 我没听过你弹这个
Choiszt: I've never heard you play this.
Shure: 你弹弹就行
Shure: Just play it, it'll be fine.
Katrina: 你没听过这歌
Katrina: You've never heard this song?
Shure: 哎OK OK
Shure: Oh, OK, OK.
男嘉宾:喂 喂
Male Guest: Hello, hello.
Alice:给
Alice: Here.
Alice:擦过了哈哈哈
Alice: I wiped it, hahaha.
Alice:不用这么客气
Alice: No need to be so polite.
Shure: 怎么还整俩碗呢
Shure: Why are there two bowls?
Shure: 结拜了是吗
Shure: Are we becoming sworn brothers?
Katrina: 哎这是啥意思
Katrina: Hey, what's that supposed to mean?
Alice:让我过去
Alice: Let me through.
Shure: 我要那 就要 还没
Shure: I want that, just haven't...
Alice:你要吗露西哦你不能喝哦
Alice: Do you want it, Lucia? Oh, you can't drink.
Lucia:我不喝
Lucia: I don't drink.
Alice:刘婷你喝不喝
Alice: Liu Ting, do you want to drink?
Alice:你别喝了
Alice: You better not.
Alice:小孩不让喝酒
Alice: Kids can't drink alcohol.
Lucia:这不是饮料这是水
Lucia: This isn't a drink, it's water.
Shure: 可以可以哇哈哈哈
Shure: Alright, alright, hahaha.
男嘉宾:用碗
Male Guest: Using a bowl.
Shure: 你说啥
Shure: What did you say?
Alice:没杯子
Alice: No cups.
Lucia:微醺
Lucia: Slightly tipsy.
Shure: 纯饮一碗是吧
Shure: Pure drink in a bowl, right?
Katrina: 农夫山泉微醺水
Katrina: Nongfu Spring Mild Drunken Water
Jack: 可以可以
Jack: Sure, sure
Shure: 随便随便
Shure: Whatever, whatever
Katrina: 行你两个小时确实有点
Katrina: Okay, two hours is indeed a bit
Alice:你喝吗 哦你不喝
Alice: Are you drinking? Oh, you're not drinking
Alice:我今晚怎么回事
Alice: What's wrong with me tonight?
Lucia:一顿乱回
Lucia: A total mess
Jack: 可以啊 厉害呀
Jack: Sure, impressive
Jake:手挺狠啊
Jake: Quite a strong hand
Jack: 要喝好啊
Jack: If you want to drink, go ahead
Alice:紫棠你要吗
Alice: Zitang, do you want some?
Katrina: 拜拜拜拜
Katrina: Bye, bye
Alice:我下去给你找个杯子啥的
Alice: I'll go get you a cup or something
Shure: 哎呀不好
Shure: Oh no
Alice:你不要吗
Alice: You don't want it?
Alice:你要吗你要吗
Alice: Do you want it? Do you want it?
Alice:我给你找个容器
Alice: I'll get you a container
Jack: 啥也不可以
Jack: Nothing is allowed
Alice:我给你拿个
Alice: I'll get you a
Alice:拿个容器
Alice: Get a container
Alice:虽然我自己也不在 我来都来了
Alice: Even though I'm not here, I came anyway
Jake:哎呀 我真傻
Jake: Oh, I'm so silly
Shure: 哎哟 嗨 嗨 嗨 嗨 嗨
Shure: Oh wow, wow, wow, wow, wow
Shure: 还有还有还有还有还有还有还有还有
Shure: More, more, more, more, more, more, more, more
Jake: 真傻了这个哈哈哈
Jake: This is really silly, haha
Lucia:咋啦
Lucia: What's up?
Jake:你也正好壮点胆
Jake: You should be brave
Jake:对 报应
Jake: Yeah, karma
Shure: 你你你先溜了吧
Shure: You, you, you better slip away first
Shure: 你先找一会去吧你
Shure: Go find something to do first
Lucia:我觉得还不错
Lucia: I think it's not bad
Jake:哎人呢
Jake: Hey, where is everyone?
Lucia:来点吗
Lucia: Want some?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah
Jake:哦好这就是我们5天的排练结果
Jake: Oh well, this is the result of our 5-day rehearsal
Shure: 我给你给你
Shure: I'll give it to you
Shure: 声音开小点好不好哦
Shure: Turn down the volume, okay?
Jake:十分默契
Jake: Very coordinated
Shure: 人没上来
Shure: No one came up
Lucia:基本上只能靠默契
Lucia: Basically, we can only rely on coordination
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
女嘉宾:这边
Female Guest: Over here
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no
Shure: 一般一般一般
Shure: Just okay, just okay
Jake:好好
Jake: Alright, alright
Shure: 这个这个
Shure: This one, this one
Jake:你呀 你
Jake: You, you
Jake:这个数据集是不是全球独一份 老板
Jake: Is this dataset unique in the world, boss?
Jake:确实
Jake: For sure
Shure: 就我们这数据集的价值我跟你讲
Shure: Let me tell you, the value of this dataset
Shure: 无可估量
Shure: Is immeasurable
Shure: 我开始学老板反向画饼哈哈哈
Shure: I'm starting to learn from the boss how to hype things up, haha
Jake:太 确实
Jake: Too true, indeed
Shure: 来吧你给我倒回去吧
Shure: Come on, rewind it for me
Shure: 放这吧放这吧
Shure: Put it here, put it here
Shure: 我倒回去
Shure: I'll rewind it
Alice:给你拿巧克力
Alice: Here's some chocolate for you
Lucia:谢谢
Lucia: Thanks
Jake:就朝着弱智吧那路去了
Jake: Heading straight down the path of foolishness
Alice:恩将仇报是吧
Alice: Biting the hand that feeds you, huh?
Shure: 我们我们
Shure: We, we
Shure: 这个是人类
Shure: This is human
Shure: 其实是一些正常的活动
Shure: Actually, these are just normal activities
Jake:哎正常活动
Jake: Yeah, normal activities
Jake:都很正常
Jake: It's all very normal
Shure: 不不不造作
Shure: Not at all pretentious
Shure: 不
Shure: No
Jake:就 就你不喝酒就唱不上去
Jake: If you don't drink, you can't sing well
Jake:这很的
Jake: That's really
Shure: 对
Shure: Right
Jake:对 这个就
Jake: Yeah, that just
Shure: AI根本想不到这点对吧
Shure: AI can't even think of this, right?
Shure: 能啊
Shure: It can
Jack: 你错过了
Jack: You missed it
Jake:再来一次
Jake: Let's do it again
Jack: 精彩发言
Jack: Great speech
男嘉宾:你说高不高呢
Male Guest: Do you think it's high?
Jack: 这样
Jack: Like this
Jack: 这你 你先说
Jack: You, you go first
Jack: 你说高不高吧
Jack: Do you think it's high?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
Shure: 哎我靠
Shure: Oh, damn
Shure: 来吧女嘉宾
Shure: Come on, lady guest
Alice:吃提拉米苏不吃
Alice: Do you want to eat tiramisu or not?
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on
Alice:我给你切一个吧
Alice: I'll cut you a piece
男嘉宾:刚刚喝酒干嘛呢
Male guest: What were you doing while drinking?
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah
Alice:拿着啊
Alice: Hold it
男嘉宾:你已经忘了喝酒干嘛了
Male guest: You've already forgotten why you were drinking
Jake:呵呵看来喝挺多
Jake: Haha, looks like you drank a lot
男嘉宾:已经倒半天了
Male guest: It's been pouring for a while
Alice:这有水
Alice: There's water here
男嘉宾:嗯
Male guest: Hmm
Alice:行
Alice: Okay
Alice:别玩抽象
Alice: Don't play abstract
Shure: 词写上了
Shure: The words are written
Jake:有 有词有词
Jake: Yeah, there are words
Shure: 呃你稍微放大一点
Shure: Uh, enlarge it a bit
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh
Shure: 刘帅好OK
Shure: Choiszt, good, OK
Shure: 然后你来翻谱对OK
Shure: Then you turn the score, right, OK
Jake:我 我来给你播
Shure: 这回能看清了吧
Shure: Can you see it clearly this time?
Shure: 我
Shure: I
男嘉宾:倒酒
Male guest: Pour the wine
Shure: 来吧来吧拿 过来
Shure: Come on, come on, pass it over
Alice:我给你拿个勺子类的东西
Alice: I'll get you something like a spoon
Shure: 来吧准备
Shure: Come on, get ready
Shure: 可以了
Shure: It's done
Alice:你修修图啊稍等我
Alice: You edit the picture, wait for me
Shure:  一段就可以了
Shure: Just one part is fine
Jack: 你有没有拍下去呢
Jack: Did you take the picture?
男嘉宾:刚刚发生了什么
Male guest: What just happened?
Jake:啊没看见
Jake: Ah, didn't see it
Alice:什么什么什么
Alice: What, what, what?
Alice:波啦
Alice: Oh no
Jake:OK OK没关系这边有个机会
Jake: OK, OK, no problem, there's another chance here
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh dear
Katrina: 我今天晚上受不了了
Katrina: I can't take it anymore tonight
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Katrina: 啊真难受
Katrina: Ah, this is really tough.
Katrina: 点一首唯一
Katrina: Play "The Only One."
Alice:在来一块
Alice: Let's do another one.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Nicous: 小黄 唱吧
Nicous: Nicous, sing it.
Katrina: E了
Katrina: Eww.
Shure: 您来唱
Shure: You sing.
Katrina: 真E了
Katrina: Really eww.
男嘉宾:咱心里
Male Guest: In our hearts...
男嘉宾:也是难以
Male Guest: It's also hard...
Tasha:也是男女
Tasha: It's also men and women...
Shure: 我不会
Shure: I can't.
Shure的女友:那首我真不会
Shure's GF: I really can't sing that one.
Shure的女友:这首还唱过
Shure's GF: I've sung this one before.
Shure的女友:那首真不会
Shure's GF: But not that one.
男嘉宾:OK
Male Guest: OK.
男嘉宾:告五人的是不是王力宏的
Male Guest: Is it by Accusefive or Leehom Wang?
Shure: 对 告5人的
Shure: Yes, it's by Accusefive.
Shure: 告五人的
Shure: It's by Accusefive.
Shure: 告5人的
Shure: By Accusefive.
Shure: 告五人你弹的是王力宏的
Shure: You played Leehom Wang's version.
Shure: 你谈的是王力宏的啊
Shure: You played Leehom Wang's version, huh?
男嘉宾:这是告五人的吗
Male Guest: Is this by Accusefive?
Jack: 啊告五人
Jack: Ah, Accusefive.
Jack: 这这这跟那个有什么区别吗
Jack: What's the difference between this and that?
Nicous: 是两个两个
Nicous: They're two different...
Shure: 完全不一样的歌
Shure: Completely different songs.
Nicous: 完全不一样
Nicous: Totally different.
Shure: 两种不一样
Shure: Two different kinds.
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Katrina: 我真的能唱吗
Katrina: Can I really sing this?
Shure: 你可以的
Shure: You can do it.
Katrina: 来
Katrina: Let's go.
Shure: 你不行少和弦就行
Shure: If you can't, just play fewer chords.
Katrina: 你帮我合着点
Katrina: Help me harmonize.
Shure: 我还帮你合着点
Shure: I'll help you harmonize.
Katrina: 就大家帮我合着点
Katrina: Everyone help me harmonize.
Katrina: 我一个人唱我的声音我会觉得很尴尬
Katrina: Singing alone makes me feel embarrassed.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 我看从哪开始
Katrina: Let me see where to start.
Katrina: 我靠挺好我不知道从哪进
Katrina: Wow, it's pretty nice, but I don't know where to enter.
Alice:吃提拉米苏吗我给你切一块
Alice: Want some tiramisu? I'll cut you a piece.
Katrina: 你能提示一下吗
Katrina: Can you give me a hint?
Lucia:我下午吃了
Lucia: I had some this afternoon.
Alice:他说挺好吃的
Alice: He said it was pretty good.
Lucia:对我也觉得挺好吃的
Lucia: Yeah, I think it's pretty good too.
Lucia:是吧
Lucia: Right?
Katrina: 我也觉得
Katrina: I think so too.
Alice:吃提拉米苏吗我给你切一块
Alice: Want some tiramisu? I'll cut you a piece.
Shure: 哎我直接弹了得了
Shure: Hey, I'll just play it directly.
Shure: 来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure的女友:我吃过了
Shure's GF: I've already had some.
Alice:你要吗
Alice: Do you want some?
Lucia:我们俩一起吃的
Lucia: We ate it together.
Shure: 你这怎么D调你知道吗
Shure: Do you know how to transpose this to D?
Alice:你要吗给你切一下
Alice: Do you want some? I'll cut you a piece.
男嘉宾:我从来不用这些
Male Guest: I never use these.
Alice:我得给你找个容器
Alice: I need to find you a container.
Shure: 我草
Shure: Oh crap.
Shure: 你给我移个调我就可以可以
Shure: Just transpose it for me and I can manage.
Alice:给你用这个吧
Alice: Use this one.
Katrina: 这是在干什么呢
Katrina: What's going on here?
Alice:你在乱叫
Alice: You're making a fuss.
Alice:妈我杀了你
Alice: Mom, I'm going to kill you.
Shure: 等一下啊
Shure: Hold on a second.
Shure: 我稍等我稍微移个调就可以
Shure: Wait a bit, I'll just transpose it slightly.
Shure: 你怎么移调啊
Shure: How do you transpose?
男嘉宾:这歌你没听过吗
Male Guest: Haven't you heard this song before?
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Katrina: 没听过吗
Katrina: Haven't you heard it before?
Nicous: 哦这这这这这个
Nicous: Oh, this, this, this one.
Jake:这两天来少了
Jake: You've been coming less these past few days.
男嘉宾:不会每天都唱吧
Male Guest: You don't sing this every day, right?
Katrina: 每天都唱这首歌一到晚上
Katrina: We sing this song every night.
Jake:每天都唱
Jake: Every day.
Shure: 要不这个我帮你弹
Shure: How about I play this for you?
男嘉宾:啊
Male Guest: Huh?
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh.
Shure: 你这调对吗你想想
Shure: Are you sure this tune is right? Think about it.
Alice:露西亚让我过一下下
Alice: Lucia, can you let me through for a bit?
Lucia:啊好的
Lucia: Ah, sure.
Alice:哎我看有点
Alice: Oh, I see a bit of...
Lucia:这个呃是不是还要在
Lucia: Is this, uh, do we still need to...
Alice:噢噢谢谢
Alice: Oh, oh, thank you.
Lucia:没事
Lucia: No problem.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Mm-hmm.
Jake:谢彬竹没搞定
Jake: Xie Binzhu hasn't got it done.
Shure: 你就全程在这翻手机
Shure: You've been flipping through your phone the whole time.
Shure: 你在你在后面有什么用
Shure: What's the point of you being in the back?
Shure: 四级
Shure: Level four.
Shure: 然后你往上移半个调不就得了吗
Shure: Then just move up half a step, won't you get it?
Shure: 笨死了可
Shure: You're so dumb.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Ugh.
Katrina: 从头吗
Katrina: From the start?
Jack: 从头吧
Jack: From the start.
Shure: OK能不能找到了哥
Shure: OK, can you find it, bro?
Shure: 这次
Shure: This time.
Shure: 这这次
Shure: This, this time.
Shure: 那我就给你声开大点了啊
Shure: I'll turn up the volume for you.
Alice:要哪个
Alice: Which one do you want?
Shure: 真没有问题了
Shure: There's really no problem now.
Shure: 哈哈哈哎
Shure: Hahaha, alright.
Nicous: 准备
Nicous: Ready?
Jake:你又行了了是吧
Jake: You're good now, right?
Shure: 他又行了
Shure: He's good now.
Alice:行
Alice: Okay.
Shure: 能不能找到他哥
Shure: Can you find him, bro?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Shure: 那刚才不是完事了吗
Shure: Wasn't it done just now?
Alice:能给我发个消息吗找不着你了
Alice: Can you send me a message? I can't find you.
Shure: 好终于对上了
Shure: Finally, it's right.
Alice:太卡了
Alice: It's too laggy.
Shure: 你在你在后面有什么用
Shure: What's the point of you being in the back?
Katrina: 来
Katrina: Come on.
Alice:搜不到
Alice: Can't find it.
Jake:你真的懂
Jake: Do you really understand?
Jake:呀
Jake: Ah.
Katrina: OK哦
Katrina: OK.
Katrina: 换下一首
Katrina: Next song, please.
Shure: 还有要表演的同学
Shure: Anyone else wants to perform?
男嘉宾:靖康
Male Guest: Jingkang.
Shure: 靖康你会唱什么
Shure: Jingkang, what can you sing?
Katrina: 唱一首
Katrina: Sing a song.
Shure: 这老板得唱一首吧
Shure: The boss should sing a song, right?
Shure: 唱什么老板啊
Shure: What should the boss sing?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
男嘉宾:你会唱什么
Male Guest: What can you sing?
Katrina: 爱拼才会赢
Katrina: "Love to Win."
Jake:行来
Jake: Sure, let's do it.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 老板真会唱吗
Shure: Can the boss really sing?
Jake:不会
Jake: No.
Shure: 老板会会
Shure: The boss can sing a bit.
Shure: 会唱点什么吗
Shure: Can you sing something?
Alice:yes OK
Alice: Yes, OK.
女嘉宾:are you OK
Female Guest: Are you OK?
Jake:are you OK
Jake: Are you OK?
Alice:他的手机铃声
Alice: That's his ringtone.
Jake:are you OK这个倒是可以
Jake: "Are you OK" could work.
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh no.
Lucia:婧康的手机铃声
Lucia: That's Jingkang's ringtone.
Alice:are you OK
Alice: Are you OK?
Jake:are you OK
Alice:hello
Alice: Hello?
Shure: 那我
Shure: Then I...
Shure: 这怎么办呢
Shure: What should we do?
Shure: 这这大家以后你看
Shure: You see, everyone...
Shure: 这就是一个情商小课堂
Shure: This is an emotional intelligence class.
男嘉宾:富士山下
Male Guest: "Under Mount Fuji."
男嘉宾:哦
Male Guest: Oh.
Jack: 可以可以
Jack: Sure, sure.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
Alice:我现在就去山东进修
Alice:呃山东
Alice: Uh, Shandong.
Alice:呃哈哈哈哈
Alice: Uh, hahaha.
Alice:情商小课堂
Alice: Emotional intelligence class.
Shure: are you OK哈喽
Shure: Are you OK, hello?
Lucia:我靠
Lucia: Oh my god.
Shure: 老板来
Shure: Boss, come here.
Shure: 我觉得这样也可以
Shure: I think this works too.
Shure: 咱们也不尴尬
Shure: We won't feel awkward.
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need.
Jake:用不着
Jake: No need.
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need.
Shure: 要成功哈哈哈
Shure: We need to succeed, haha.
Jake:先打
Jake: Let's start.
Lucia:不是谁是老板啊
Lucia: Wait, who is the boss?
Shure: 老板老板
Shure: Boss, boss.
Jake:用不着
Jake: No need.
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need.
Jake:呃算了
Jake: Uh, forget it.
Jake:哈哈挺会
Jake: Haha, well done.
Katrina: 这弹啥了
Katrina: What did you play?
Shure: 他把老板的歌词给弹了
Shure: He played the boss's lyrics.
Shure: 这种一般都怎么处理呢
Shure: How do we usually handle this?
Alice:送去山东
Alice: Send him to Shandong.
Jack: 不趁着人多的时候说话知道不
Jack: Don't talk when there are many people around, got it?
Shure: 我感觉这样
Shure: I think this way...
Shure: 明天他左脚就可能踏进公司了吧
Shure: By tomorrow, he might step into the company with his left foot.
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh...
Katrina: 那个唱富士山下
Katrina: Sing "Under the Mount Fuji."
Shure: 所以所以XBZ
Shure: So, so, XBZ.
Jack: 可以
Jack: Sure.
Shure: 你你在这里的
Shure: You, you are here...
Katrina: 起一个什么作用呢
Katrina: What's your role here?
Shure: 气氛组
Shure: Atmosphere team.
Katrina: 起一个logo作用哈哈哈
Katrina: Like a logo, haha.
Shure: logo怎么这牌子
Shure: A logo? How did this brand...
Shure: 打钱了是吗
Shure: Get paid?
Katrina: 唱点经典的
Katrina: Sing some classics.
Katrina: 大家都会的
Katrina: Songs everyone knows.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina: 周杰伦陈奕迅
Katrina: Jay Chou, Eason Chan.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Jack: 可不可以又弹又跳一条龙
Jack: Can we play and dance, all in one go?
男嘉宾:这有点难
Male Guest: That's a bit tough.
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello.
Shure: 没事看看你
Shure: It's okay, just checking on you.
Shure: 没事 不用不用
Shure: It's okay, no need, no need.
Katrina: 这个词有点难看到
Katrina: This word is a bit hard to see.
Shure: 对你这上不了桌回家的时候
Shure: Yeah, you can't bring this to the table when you go home.
Shure: 现在先坐小孩的时候历练2年
Shure: First, sit for two years when you're a kid.
Shure: 哼 什么好的好的
Shure: Hmph, what? Okay, okay.
Alice:好吗
Alice: Is that okay?
Alice:好的
Alice: Okay.
Katrina: 好吧好的
Katrina: Alright, okay.
Alice:好的
Alice: Okay.
Alice:大兵打人装修吗
Alice: Does the soldier hit people during renovation?
男嘉宾:来一个来一个来一个
Male Guest: Let's have one, let's have one.
Alice:再来一块吗还吃吗
Alice: Do you want another piece? Still eating?
Jack: 给你拿麦  我给你拿麦
Jack: I'll get the mic for you. I'll get the mic.
Shure: 这太浓了
Shure: This is too strong.
Jack: 我负责给你拿麦
Jack: I'll be responsible for getting the mic for you.
Shure: 就跟我
Shure: Just like me.
Shure: 要不给我就稍微倒一点
Shure: If you don't want to give it to me, just pour a little.
Alice:有但是太杂了这根本就没有一个
Alice: There are, but it's too messy. There's no single one.
Shure: 陈奕迅啊这是
Shure: This is Eason Chan.
Shure: 兑一起然后再分一半
Shure: Mix it together and then split it in half.
Shure: 我给他录一个
Shure: I'll record one for him.
Lucia:哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, amazing.
Shure: 啊他那天说的
Shure: Ah, he said that the other day.
Shure: 哇谢彬竹
Shure: Wow, Xie Bin Zhu.
Shure: 终于默契了一次
Shure: Finally, we were in sync once.
Shure: 我懂了问题出在我身上
Shure: I get it, the problem is with me.
Shure: 不是不是你身上
Shure: It's not, it's not with you.
Shure: 懂了懂了
Shure: Got it, got it.
Shure: 跟跟跟那个帅师傅比较
Shure: Comparing with Master Shuai, right?
Shure: 比较投缘是吧
Shure: We get along better, right?
Nicous: 下一个
Nicous: Next one.
Shure: 下一个
Shure: Next one.
Jake:哎别你别你别
Jake: Hey, don't, don't, don't.
Shure: 靠 好
Shure: Damn, okay.
Nicous: 你来一个
Nicous: You do one.
Jake:对你来一个
Jake: Yeah, you do one.
男嘉宾:不用啦
Male Guest: No need.
Shure: 我们有全民K歌
Shure: We have Karaoke for Everyone.
Katrina: 实在不行普通朋友
Katrina: If it doesn't work out, just be regular friends.
男嘉宾:普通朋友
Male Guest: Regular friends.
Katrina: 大家一起唱就没事
Katrina: If everyone sings together, it'll be fine.
Katrina: 来来来
Katrina: Come on, let's go.
Katrina: RNB是非常适合这种氛围的
Katrina: R&B really suits this kind of vibe.
Katrina: 没关系挺可爱
Katrina: It's okay, it's cute.
Katrina: 没事
Katrina: It's fine.
Shure的女友:都很喜欢
Shure's GF: Everyone likes it.
Jack: 给给给找个词呗
Jack: Give us a word, please.
男嘉宾:哦
Male Guest: Oh.
Shure: 发完了记得删
Shure: Remember to delete it after sending.
Shure: 别被你女朋友发现了
Shure: Don't let your girlfriend find out.
Shure: 你不是孤优从立
Shure: You're not alone in this.
Jake:把手扳了
Jake: Turn it over.
Shure: 很好
Shure: Very good.
Shure: 加入了最后一句
Shure: Added the last line.
Shure: 具有个人特色的rap部分
Shure: The part with personal rap style.
Shure: 这谢彬竹每次最后一下叮一下就是哎
Shure: Every time Xie Binzhu adds that final touch, it's like...
Shure: 非点睛一下
Shure: It's the highlight.
Shure: 就是除了内我基本没听清哈哈哈
Shure: Besides that, I didn't catch much, haha.
Nicous: 两条进不去啊没歌词
Nicous: Two lines can't fit, there's no lyrics.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 好该谁了
Shure: Okay, whose turn is it?
Shure: 到谁了
Shure: Who's up next?
Katrina: 会弹的不就你们两个吗
Katrina: Aren't you two the ones who can play?
男嘉宾:对呀
Male Guest: Yeah.
Katrina: 点歌呗
Katrina: Just pick a song.
Shure: 主要我我唱的
Shure: Mainly, I'm the one singing.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 你点个呗
Katrina: You pick one.
Shure: 好别摘不下来
Shure: Alright, make sure it doesn't get stuck.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 这个这个呢
Shure: How about this one?
男嘉宾:好摘
Male Guest: It's easy to pick.
Shure: 那如果摘不下来呢
Shure: But what if it doesn't come off?
男嘉宾:好摘
Male Guest: It's easy to pick.
Shure: 哦只要不丢就行
Shure: As long as we don't lose it, it's fine.
Shure: 但是手指手指可以去是吧
Shure: But the fingers can go, right?
Nicous: 这什么
Nicous: What's this?
Shure: 淘汰
Shure: Eliminated.
Katrina: 前面怎么唱来着
Katrina: How did the beginning go?
Shure: 这也不能顶
Shure: This can't stand.
Shure: 那我那我先摘一个
Shure: Let me take one first.
Shure: 摘不下来的时候
Shure: When it can't be taken off...
Shure的女友:哎呀别别别别别
Shure's GF: Oh no, no, no, no, no.
Shure: 到时候跟我妈妈哭
Shure: Then I'll cry to my mom.
Shure: 妈妈你看
Shure: Mom, look.
Shure: 他把我这个戒指抢走还摘不下来
Shure: He took my ring and can't take it off.
Shure: 妈给他剁了哈
Shure: Mom, cut it off for him.
Shure的女友:我知道不能丢
Shure's GF: I know I can't lose it.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay.
Shure的女友:这个丢了我真哭给你看
Shure's GF: If I lose this, I'll really cry.
Shure: 我知道我知道
Shure: I know, I know.
Katrina: 受不了了
Katrina: I can't take it anymore.
Katrina: 这对小情侣
Katrina: This couple...
Katrina: 我怎么看不清词啊
Katrina: Why can't I see the lyrics clearly?
Shure: 几天怎么这么爱我
Shure: Why are you so in love with me these days?
Shure: 多爽啊
Shure: It's so nice.
Shure: 还每天能拿300块
Shure: And I can get 300 bucks every day.
Shure的女友:没有其实每个周末跟你出去玩的话
Shure's GF: Actually, if we go out every weekend...
Katrina: 直接拍情侣写真了
Katrina: Just take couple photos directly.
Shure的女友:会是在正常生活中
Shure's GF: It would be in normal life.
Jake:草 这他妈怎么起来
Jake: Damn, how does this thing work?
Shure的女友:然后出现一点很失去的情况
Shure's GF: Then there might be some lost situations.
Shure的女友:但是特别好
Shure's GF: But it's really good.
Shure的女友:只要我正常生活也没有什么很好的
Shure's GF: As long as I live normally, there's nothing much.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
Katrina: 哎  哎哟什么时候我也有男朋友
Katrina: Oh, when will I have a boyfriend too?
Shure: 无妨
Shure: No worries.
Katrina: 拍一个哈哈哈
Katrina: To take a photo, haha.
Lucia:前面那些歌我都没听过
Lucia: I haven't heard those songs before.
Alice:你应该不怎么听中文歌吧
Alice: You probably don't listen to Chinese songs much, right?
Lucia:我听得比较少
Lucia: I listen to them less.
Lucia:因为我有几个很喜欢的歌手
Lucia: Because I have a few favorite singers.
Shure的女友:就你知道他们在那找吗
Shure's GF: Do you know where they find them?
Lucia:然后听他们听的比较多
Lucia: And I listen to their songs more.
Shure的女友:我上回跟Darry和顾老师
Shure's GF: Last time, I went singing with Darry and Teacher Gu.
Lucia:所以留下的听别的歌的时间就很少
Lucia: So, I have less time to listen to other songs.
Shure的女友:两个人去唱歌玩
Shure's GF: The two of them went singing.
Shure的女友:那天你也知道
Shure's GF: You knew that day too
Jake:走道没了
Jake: The hallway was gone
Shure的女友:然后就是我说陈奕迅OK这首
Shure's GF: Then I said Eason Chan’s OK this song
Shure的女友:然后他们跟我说
Shure's GF: Then they told me
Alice:有点困了
Alice: Feeling a bit sleepy
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Shure的女友:就是我找那种
Shure's GF: I was looking for that kind
Lucia:发现无法融入歌单
Lucia: Found it hard to fit into the playlist
Shure的女友:我感觉大家都会唱的歌
Shure's GF: I felt like everyone would sing
Lucia:变得I了起来
Lucia: It became I
Shure的女友:他说OK这一首我好像知道
Shure's GF: He said OK this song, I think I know it
Alice:没事你本来就I 无所谓
Alice: It's okay, you’re naturally I, doesn't matter
Shure的女友:但是我不会唱
Shure's GF: But I can’t sing it
Katrina: 周杰伦还有什么歌
Katrina: What other songs does Jay Chou have
Shure的女友:然后你在说什么
Shure's GF: Then what were you saying
Shure的女友:那你为什么要找粤语歌
Shure's GF: Why are you looking for Cantonese songs
Shure的女友:你找粤语歌
Shure's GF: You look for Cantonese songs
Shure的女友:你不找伊森的歌
Shure's GF: You don’t look for Ethan’s songs
Shure的女友:什么东西
Shure's GF: What the heck
Shure的女友:最后唱的什么
Shure's GF: What was the last song
Shure的女友:就是反正大家会唱粤语歌
Shure's GF: Anyway, everyone can sing Cantonese songs
Shure的女友:但是唱的什么我也不知道
Shure's GF: But what they sang, I don’t know
Shure的女友:忘记了忘记了
Shure's GF: Forgot, forgot
Shure: 东北人有自己的一套粤语体系
Shure: Northeastern people have their own Cantonese system
Shure: 知道吗哈哈哈哈
Shure: You know, hahaha
Shure的女友:不是啊戴瑞家山西的啊
Shure's GF: No, Derry’s family is from Shanxi
Alice:他没带走
Alice: He didn’t take it away
Lucia:好可爱
女嘉宾:戴瑞是山西人
Female guest: Derry is from Shanxi
Katrina: 这我也听过
Katrina: I’ve heard this too
Katrina: 这不是高中的时候
Katrina: Isn’t this from high school
Shure的女友:我忘了山西哪里了
Shure's GF: I forgot which part of Shanxi
Shure的女友:但反正是山西人
Shure's GF: But anyway, he’s from Shanxi
Lucia:不要拆散我们的小狗cp
Lucia: Don’t break up our puppy CP
Katrina: 听的诗班淡淡的
Katrina: Listening to choir, faintly
Lucia:刚好
Lucia: Just right
Alice:那狗子CP
Alice: That puppy CP
Lucia:狗子CP嗯
Lucia: Puppy CP, yeah
Lucia:好可爱真可爱这花花也做得好好
Lucia: So cute, really cute, this flower is done so well
Alice:你可以把这个头拆走
Alice: You can take this head away
Katrina: 哈哈这首好适合吉他弹
Katrina: Haha, this song is perfect for guitar playing.
Lucia:我去找一个你拆
Lucia: I'll go find one, you can disassemble it.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Lucia:啊 谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thank you.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mhm.
Alice:没事你喜欢的话你拿走也行
Alice: No problem, if you like it, you can take it.
Shure的女友:啊就是拍卖的开辟
Shure's GF: Ah, so the auction has started.
Shure的女友:已经不属于他的买家了是吗
Shure's GF: It's no longer the buyer's, right?
Jack: 对呀
Jack: Yeah.
Alice:对
Alice: Yes.
Lucia:对对
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Jack: 啊好过分啊
Jack: Ah, that's so unfair.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:困了有点
Alice: I'm a bit sleepy.
Alice:我真的困了
Alice: I'm really sleepy.
Shure: 自已倒啊
Shure: Go to sleep then.
Shure的女友:气泡水和朗姆其实还可以
Shure's GF: Sparkling water and rum actually go well together.
Shure: 洗发水应该买的
Shure: We should have bought shampoo.
Shure的女友:但我感觉
Shure's GF: But I feel...
Shure的女友:我感觉它最好
Shure's GF: I feel the best...
Shure的女友:其实是伏特加是最好的
Shure's GF: Actually, vodka is the best.
Shure的女友:但是不知道为什么你们没买
Shure's GF: But I don't know why you guys didn't buy it.
Shure: 我有半瓶一直说要带来的
Shure: I had half a bottle that I kept saying I'd bring.
Shure: 一直谁过来的时候都忘了带
Shure: But I always forgot to bring it whenever I came over.
Shure的女友:像罗舒兰这种东西
Shure's GF: Like something from Rosulan.
Shure的女友:我觉得他只适合做少婷
Shure's GF: I think it's only suitable for cocktails.
但Shure的女友:你买一瓶罗舒兰
Shure's GF: If you buy a bottle of Rosulan...
Shure的女友:我其实不是很不是很理解
Shure's GF: I actually don't really, don't really understand.
Shure的女友:不是很理解就是这种
Shure's GF: I don't really understand.
他虽然那个入口特别好
Shure's GF: Even though it tastes really good...
Shure的女友:但是他他对我来说只适合做绍兴
Shure's GF: But to me, it's only suitable for making Shaoxing.
Shure的女友:前几年真的挺流行
Shure's GF: A few years ago, it was really popular.
Shure的女友:真的
Shure's GF: Really.
Shure的女友:但是但是
Shure's GF: But, but...
Shure的女友:在网易云的那个归类里面
Shure's GF: In the NetEase Cloud categorization...
Shure的女友:功德被归到了说唱
Shure's GF: Gongde was categorized as rap.
Shure的女友:i mean the why
Shure's GF: I mean, why?
Shure: 因为他有他有关联的
Shure: Because it has some connections.
Shure: 比如说像豆芽这种课
Shure: For example, like Douya's class.
Shure的女友:可能all right
Shure: rap是多吧
Shure: 又开始了
Shure的女友:对对对
Shure的女友:但他不是他不是
Shure的女友:他真的不是
Shure的女友:你可以把归到任何一个类
Shure的女友:就是甚至你把归到华语大流行都行
Shure的女友:但他真的不是说唱
Shure的女友:其实你可以把我背到口中
Shure的女友:我也不知道
Shure的女友:音乐人的乐园
Shure: 谁知道
Alice:我看着拉炼我呢
Lucia:噢
Alice:我一定看好吗
Alice:我一定看啊
Alice:结束了吗还是什么
Alice:这是干嘛
Alice:什么环节
Lucia:无法融入歌单
Lucia:大部分都没听过
Lucia: I haven't heard most of these songs.
Shure: 给你胖了
Shure: You're getting chubby.
Shure: 你不是怕被踢了
Shure: Aren't you afraid of being kicked out?
Alice:什么刘婷要唱凤凰传奇
Alice: What, Liu Ting is going to sing Phoenix Legend?
Shure的女友:高了高了高了
Shure's GF: Too high, too high, too high.
Lucia:没有谱子
Lucia: I don't have the sheet music.
Lucia:可是伴奏同学依然会弹
Lucia: But the accompanist still knows how to play.
Jack: 果然这个歌词你不会了
Jack: Looks like you don't know the lyrics after all.
Alice:后面不会了
Alice: I don't know the rest.
Jack: 找一下词好吗
Jack: Can you find the lyrics?
Shure的女友:啊不这种歌只要记住副歌就行
Shure's GF: Oh no, for this kind of song, just remember the chorus.
Alice:凤凰传奇上
Alice: Phoenix Legend is up next.
刘婷:我其实也不太会唱
Liu Ting: I'm actually not really good at singing it.
Jake:再找一个再找一个
Jake: Find another one, find another one.
Jack: 除了副歌的词一遍也记不住
Jack: I can't remember any of the lyrics except for the chorus.
刘婷:主要是上吧
Liu Ting: The main thing is to just go for it.
Alice:上吧上吧
Alice: Just go for it, go for it.
刘婷:图个氛围
Liu Ting: It's all about the vibe.
刘婷:不是我会
Liu Ting: It's not that I can sing it well.
Shure: 不我们有
Shure: No, we have...
Shure: 我们有全民k歌这个软件的
Shure: We have the "全民K歌" app.
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: You know that?
Jack: 分分钟需要你
Jack: "分分钟需要你"
男嘉宾:都不太会唱
Male Guest: I don't really know how to sing.
Shure的女友:啊不刚刚他就在啊
Shure's GF: Oh no, he was just here.
Shure的女友:刚刚还跟我说说为什么不能唱那个啊
Shure's GF: He just told me why he couldn't sing that one.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Oh.
Shure的女友:就是就是就是
Shure's GF: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shure: 我们有有有
Shure: We have, we have.
Shure: 全民k歌的
Shure: The "全民K歌" app.
Jack: 为什么没有唱吧之类的
Jack: Why not something like "唱吧"?
Shure: 来来来我们是有的
Shure: Come on, we have it.
Shure: 大家
Shure: Everyone.
Jack: 吉他这边就自个看
Jack: Check the guitar over here.
Jack: 然后我们另外一个手机
Jack: And then another phone.
Jack: 放在KTV的那个
Jack: Put it in the KTV spot.
男嘉宾:对对对来吧
Male Guest: Yeah, yeah, let's do it.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's go.
Shure: 我们其实早就为了这个k歌程序的啊
Shure: We've actually been using this karaoke app for a while.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
男嘉宾:婧康真的不要高歌一曲
Male Guest: Jingkang, you really don't want to sing?
男嘉宾:这可是我们宝贵的数据资源车呀
Male Guest: This is our precious data resource vehicle.
Alice:今天
Alice: Today...
男嘉宾:468861哦你摄影他就要拍了
Male Guest: 468861, oh, you're filming, he's about to shoot.
男嘉宾:然后就不会说两个一起的
Male Guest: And then they won't do it together.
男嘉宾:也有道理啊
Male Guest: Makes sense, huh?
Tasha:把电脑拿给我呗
Tasha: Hand me the computer.
Shure: 唉好
Shure: Oh, okay.
Tasha:还有 对
Tasha: And, yeah.
Tasha:搞不完了快
Tasha: Hurry up, we can't finish this.
Shure的女友:你可以就是
Shure's GF: You could just...
Alice:写完
Alice: Finish writing.
男嘉宾:陈奕迅的粤语歌词
Male Guest: Eason Chan's Cantonese lyrics.
男嘉宾:我的粤语都是来吧
Male Guest: My Cantonese is all "come on."
Shure: 来吧咱们
Shure: Come on, let's...
Shure: 咱们可以点了
Shure: We can choose it.
男嘉宾:海阔天空
Male Guest: "海阔天空"
Jack: 我来搜一搜
Jack: I'll search for it.
男嘉宾:因为我去KTV就唱了哪些歌
Male Guest: Because when I go to KTV, these are the songs I sing.
Nicous: 我下班了吧
Shure: 对你可以下班了
Shure: 操
Shure: 咱开 4块钱
Shure: 4块钱杨老板能报一下不到1新币
Jake:多少钱
男嘉宾:4块
Shure: 4块
Jake:4块多少新币
Shure: 0.8新币
Jake:那有点超预算了
Jake:哈哈哈买买买
男嘉宾:838080高
女嘉宾:已经四五年了
男嘉宾:我我唱情非得已
Jack: 他们有那个什么网
Jack: 有那个什么情歌网
Shure的女友:麦给我麦给我
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: 现在有吗
Shure: Is it working now?
Shure的女友:有有有
Shure's GF: Yes, yes, yes
Shure: 有是吧
Shure: There is, right?
Shure: 有吧
Shure: OK OK
Shure: OK, OK.
Shure: 再再试一下
Shure: Let's try again.
Shure: 现在有了OK
Shure: Now it's working, OK.
Jack: 哎呀
Jack: Oh no.
Shure: 稍等稍等
Shure: Hold on, hold on.
Shure: 我把把这个PPT退掉啊
Shure: I'll close this PPT.
Shure: OK OK这回就
Shure: OK, OK, now it's fine.
Jake:有时候压力比较大
Jake: Sometimes the pressure is quite high.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my.
Jack: 情非得已来
Jack: Inevitably, it comes.
Katrina: 来
Katrina: Here it comes.
Jack: 我切了啊
Jack: I'll cut it off, okay?
Shure: 啊不不保存
Shure: Ah no, don't save it.
Shure: 所有的都不保存你
Shure: Don't save any of it.
Shure: 大家想让我保存吗
Shure: Do you all want me to save it?
Nicous: 唉 给他们存着
Nicous: Sigh, save it for them.
Jake:没关系没关系
Jake: It's alright, it's alright.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:我从刚下来吃水果
Lucia: I just came down to eat some fruit.
Jake:检查工作
Jake: Checking work.
Jake:例行检查
Jake: Routine check.
Shure: 为什么这首歌
Shure: Why this song?
Katrina: 我的线呢
Katrina: Where's my cable?
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:就就例行检查这个灯亮不亮
Jake: Just, just routine check to see if this light works.
Jake:就吃水果是一个好表现
Jake: Eating fruit is a good thing.
Jake:但是灯不亮就不行
Jake: But if the light doesn't work, that's not good.
Jake:对对对就就水果就白吃了
Jake: Yeah, yeah, then the fruit is wasted.
Jake:就还得再吃一遍
Jake: You'll have to eat it again.
Lucia:你吓得我水果都不知道放哪了
Lucia: You scared me, I don't know where I put the fruit.
Katrina: 我觉得
Katrina: I think...
Jake:找线呢
Jake: Looking for the cable?
Jake:你出去找找
Jake: Go outside and look.
Tasha:说什么来着
Tasha: What were you saying?
Jake:放哪去了
Jake: Where did it go?
Katrina: 领导有个坏场所不知道他为什么
Katrina: The boss has a bad place, not sure why. 社会问题
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Jake:好吧那关了再开
Jake: Okay, then turn it off and on again.
Lucia:嗯怎么会呢
Lucia: Hmm, how could that be?
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh dear.
Lucia:啊他现在变成charging了
Lucia: Ah, now it's charging.
Lucia:嗯好吧
Lucia: Hmm, okay.
Lucia:那刚不知为什么断了对
Lucia: It just disconnected for some reason, right?
Jake:对 只要他是亮的就行
Jake: Yes, as long as it's on, it's fine.
Lucia:用户体验
Lucia: User experience.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Jake:用户还有一天可以体验
Jake: Users have one more day to experience it.
Lucia: ok
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright.
Lucia:进行一些压力测试
Lucia: Conduct some stress tests.
Jake:用户好好体验一下
Jake: Users should thoroughly experience it.
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Jake:这些都是问题
Jake: These are all issues.
Jake:刚刚为什么没有录
Jake: Why wasn't it recorded just now?
Lucia:我不知道 我也很奇怪
Lucia: I don't know, I was also confused.
Jake:因为对
Jake: Because... yeah.
Jake:是就是就是
Jake: Yes, yes, exactly.
Jake:QA我们的数据里面会有一些问题
Jake: QA, we have some issues in our data.
Jake:刚刚为什么没有
Jake: Why wasn't it there just now?
Jake:然后就可以回答
Jake: Then we can answer.
Jake:因为用户体验不行
Jake: Because the user experience is bad.
Jake:这是什么
Jake: What is this?
Tasha:嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake:这是什么
Jake: What is this?
Tasha:这是
Tasha: This is...
Tasha:唉 我明天要答辩了
Tasha: Ugh, I have a defense tomorrow.
Jake:我要大便了
Jake: I need to poop.
Jake:你要来工作
Jake: Are you coming to work?
Jake:外头吧没拿回来唉应该楼上楼上他们
Jake: Outside, didn't bring it back. Probably upstairs, upstairs them.
Jake:哈哈哈差不多
Jake: Haha, almost.
Jake:在楼上
Jake: Upstairs.
Jake:一个椅子是吧
Jake: A chair, right?
Jake:线找了吗 在哪里
Jake: Did you find the cable? Where is it?
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Jake:完了 眼镜掉了
Jake: Oh no, my glasses fell.
Jake:谢谢 谢谢
Jake: Thanks, thanks.
Jake:再拧一个
Jake: Twist another one.
Lucia:椰乳再拿一个是吧
Lucia: Another coconut milk, right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Alice:哎小心小心
Alice: Hey, be careful, be careful.
Jake:没关系 楼下再开一桌
Jake: No worries, we'll set up another table downstairs.
Jake:不对
Jake: No.
Jake:东北分会场
Jake: Northeast branch venue.
Alice:最近感觉超上火
Alice: Recently, I feel super irritable.
Alice:想洗脸了
Alice: I want to wash my face.
刘婷:去吧
Liu Ting: Go ahead.
Alice:真嘟吗
Alice: Really?
刘婷:老了到点困了有点
Liu Ting: Getting old, feeling a bit sleepy.
Alice:真的吗
Alice: Really?
刘婷:你不你不你不卸妆吗
Liu Ting: Aren't you going to remove your makeup?
Alice:卸等会卸
Alice: I'll remove it later.
Alice:洗 等我一下
Alice: Wash, wait a sec.
Alice:看还有多少
Alice: See how much is left.
Jake:那是找对地方了
Jake: Then you found the right place.
Lucia:都可以吃吧
Lucia: Can we eat all of this?
Jake:哈哈当然不是的干嘛
Jake: Haha, of course not. What are you thinking?
Lucia:请示一下领导
Lucia: Let me consult the boss.
Jake:不吃这些东西呢
Jake: What if we don't eat these things?
Jake:怎么处理呢
Jake: How should we handle it?
Alice:今天几点下班
Alice: What time do we get off work today?
Shure的女友:就是他真的只适合入手
Shure's GF: He's really only good for starting out.
Jake:好问题我也不知道
Jake: Good question, I don't know either.
Alice:困了
Alice: I'm sleepy.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Lucia:领导都 不知道几点下班
Lucia: Even the boss doesn't know what time we get off work.
Alice:领导这个不知道有点
Alice: It's a bit strange that the boss doesn't know this.
Alice:还蛮好的
Alice: It's pretty good though.
Jake:那 咱
Jake: Well, let's...
Jake:咱
Jake: Let's...
Alice:好的
Alice: Okay.
Jake:咱是咱是
Jake: Let's... let's...
Jake:算什么点
Jake: What time is it?
Jake:十一 十一  十一十一六 十一十一七
Jake: Eleven eleven... eleven sixteen, eleven seventeen.
Alice:十一十一7
Alice: Eleven seventeen.
Jake:十一十一7
Jake: Eleven seventeen.
Jake:哈哈 确实 太博学了
Jake: Haha, indeed, very knowledgeable.
Jake:这个
Jake: This...
Jake:是是是我错了我错了
Jake: Yes, yes, my bad, my bad.
Jake:这每天十一十一七的玩
Jake: Playing every day till eleven seventeen.
Jake:高强度玩耍
Jake: High-intensity play.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:11点结束之后还得网购买东西
Alice: After finishing at 11 PM, I still have to shop online.
Lucia:不要太离谱
Lucia: Don't be too ridiculous.
Jake:太高强度了
Jake: Too intense.
Alice:算加班
Alice: Consider it overtime.
Jake:还加班还加班还加班
Jake: Overtime, overtime, overtime.
Lucia:对还要加班
Lucia: Yes, still overtime.
Jake:店还没开
Jake: The store isn't even open.
Jake:好嘞好嘞
Jake: Alright, alright.
Alice:闯入人家闺房干什么啊
Alice: Why are you barging into someone's room?
刘婷:你不许进来
Liu Ting: You can't come in.
Jake:只是他不许进来哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Only he can't come in, hahaha.
Alice:倒返天罡了
Alice: This is so chaotic.
Alice:倒返天罡了这
Lucia:开始录8%居然就可以了
Lucia: Starting to record at 8% is actually enough.
Jake:对 5%以上应该是
Jake: Yeah, above 5% should be good.
Lucia:哎不愧是领导
Lucia: Wow, as expected from the boss.
Alice:哎这眼镜感觉损耗了
Alice: Oh, these glasses seem worn out.
Alice:就是这几天发现充着电还是耗电
Alice: I've noticed that even when charging, the battery still drains.
Shure的女友:因为正常大概是在5-12度
Shure's GF: Because normally it should be around 5-12 degrees.
Jake:没关系损
Jake: It's okay, wear it out.
Jake:使劲损
Jake: Use it hard.
Lucia:对刚开始我觉得差
Lucia: Yeah, at first I thought it was bad.
Alice:尊嘟 真
Alice: Really?
Jake:随便损
Jake: Wear it out however you want.
Alice:真的吗
Alice: Really?
Alice:这个如果用坏了不还要买新的吗
Alice: But if it breaks, don't we have to buy a new one?
Lucia:没事这捐给他们了
Lucia: It's okay, we donated it to them.
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh.
Jake:咱们咱项目要不
Jake: About our project...
Jack: 老板不差钱
Jack: The boss isn't short on money.
Jake:主要是捐的
Jake: Mainly because it's donated.
Jake:就主要是这批货只要不用坏就能用
Jake: As long as this batch doesn't break, we can use it.
Jake:咱下一批就下一批
Jake: We'll get the next batch.
Alice:等于说你想用新的呗
Alice: So you want to use a new one?
Jake:也不是也不是
Jake: Not really, not really.
Alice:这是可以录的吗
Alice: Can this be recorded?
Jack: 已经录下了
Jack: It's already recording.
Lucia:咦确实就算我们眼镜没开过户也开了
Lucia: Oh, even if our glasses haven't been activated, they have.
Alice:就是一直通着电之后还是一个那啥
Alice: Even when it's always charging, it's still...
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:对他还是会断我觉得
Lucia: Right, it still disconnects, I think.
Lucia:前两天没这样
Lucia: It didn't do that a couple of days ago.
Alice:一边进水一边放水还是放的快
Alice: It's like pouring water in while it's leaking out faster.
Lucia:什么小学数学题
Lucia: What kind of elementary school math problem is this?
Jack: 没事 漏得快没关系
Jack: It's fine if it leaks quickly.
Alice:小学数学题
Alice: Elementary school math problem.
Jake:挺好挺好
Jake: It's pretty good, pretty good.
Jake:就把它就是
Jake: Just use it.
Jake:最大的价值是吧 剥削掉
Jake: Get the most value out of it, right? Exploit it.
Jake:我们剥削眼镜最大的价值
Jake: We're exploiting the maximum value out of these glasses.
Lucia:你这是给眼镜配了个劳动力吧
Lucia: Are you assigning labor to the glasses?
Lucia:入职的时候公司给配发那个
Lucia: The company gave us one when we joined.
Lucia:叫什么麦克
Lucia: What's it called, Mike?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:给麦克配了个劳动力
Lucia: Got Mike a laborer.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Jake:外头还有啥吃的呀
Jake: What else is there to eat outside?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Jake:外头还有啥吃的
Jake: What else is there to eat outside?
Alice:还有披萨
Alice: There's pizza.
Alice:你饿了吗
Alice: Are you hungry?
Jake:披萨
Jake: Pizza.
Jake:我没饿我就想知道
Jake: I'm not hungry, I just want to know.
Jake:我就想看看咱们
Jake: I just want to see what we've got.
Alice:披萨披萨
Alice: Pizza, pizza.
Alice:这啥呀哦
Alice: What's this? Oh.
Alice:淄博小饼还有啊
Alice: There's still some Zibo pancakes.
Alice:这啥这啥玩意
Alice: What's this, what's this thing?
Alice:这个被挡着了
Alice: This is covered.
Alice:根本没开
Alice: It's not even opened.
Alice:我给你看着 我给你看着
Alice: I'll keep an eye on it for you.
Alice:花甲吧应该
Alice: It's probably clams.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Jake:怕是没人吃
Jake: Probably no one will eat it.
Alice:估计没看见
Alice: Probably didn't see it.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice:其实都是
Alice: Actually, it's all...
Jake:帅
Jake: Cool.
Jake:我觉得就是夜里一辆奔驰就帅
Jake: I think just a Benz at night looks cool.
Lucia:酷 很赛博朋克
Lucia: Cool, very cyberpunk.
Jake:对 就是
Jake: Yeah, exactly.
Jake:穿长裙然后亮了灯就太帅了
Jake: Wearing a long dress with lights on, just too cool.
Lucia:我们这外面要收拾一下么
Lucia: Should we clean up outside?
Lucia:哎呀感觉其实每次
Lucia: Ah, it feels like every time...
Alice:都剩一点
Alice: There's always a little left.
Lucia:对就算有剩的收拾了吃剩的吧
Lucia: Yeah, even if there's leftovers, let's clean it up and eat the leftovers.
Lucia:也不够再再点的话又多了
Lucia: It's not enough, and if we order more, there'll be too much.
Jake:不要丢掉全都丢掉
Jake: Don't throw it away, throw it all away.
Alice:老板不差钱
Alice: The boss isn't short on money.
Lucia:不会烧吧
Lucia: It won't burn, right?
Jake:还能怎么办嘛
Jake: What else can we do?
Jake:收起来有什么用
Jake: What's the use of keeping it?
Lucia:这是什么呀这是
Lucia: What is this, anyway?
Jake:花甲
Jake: Clams.
Alice:这是估计被那个饼挡着了
Alice: It was probably blocked by that cake
Lucia:哦
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:没吃
Alice: Didn't eat it.
Jake:被遗忘的花甲
Jake: The forgotten clams.
Lucia:没事反正也不吃
Lucia: It's alright, we won't eat it anyway.
Lucia:这玩意
Lucia: This stuff.
Alice:都都扔了吗
Alice: Did we throw it all away?
Alice:要不放冰箱里
Alice: How about we put it in the fridge?
Alice:明天早上万一有人吃呢
Alice: Maybe someone will eat it tomorrow morning.
Jake:那这太万一了
Jake: That's a big maybe.
Alice:昨天的汉堡还在冰箱
Alice: Yesterday's burger is still in the fridge.
Lucia:我也想起来了
Lucia: I just remembered.
Lucia:昨天的汉堡还在冰箱里 可贵了那个
Lucia: Yesterday's burger is still in the fridge. It's expensive.
Jake:确实
Jake: True.
Jake:喝点桃汁吧
Jake: Have some peach juice.
Alice:你喝吧
Alice: You drink it.
Alice:幸亏我们没有怎么淋雨
Alice: Luckily, we didn’t get too wet from the rain.
Jake:有
Jake: We did.
Alice:确实有
Alice: Yeah, we did.
Jake:上周也是这么来的是吧
Jake: It was the same last week, right?
Jake:第 就是你
Jake: You're the one
Jake:第一天晚上听到有人唱歌
Jake: who heard someone singing the first night.
Lucia:我没听到过
Lucia: I didn't hear anything.
Lucia:但是好像有个同学跟我提到过
Lucia: But I think a classmate mentioned it to me.
Lucia:说前一天好像有人啊 唱K
Lucia: Said someone was singing karaoke the night before.
Jake:噢噢 是是
Jake: Oh, oh, right.
Lucia:我不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia:我不确定那个同学是不是你
Lucia: I'm not sure if that classmate was you.
Jake:可能是我
Jake: Could be me.
Lucia:因为大家当时刚认识
Lucia: Because everyone just met back then.
Lucia:还有点拘谨和真诚
Lucia: We were still a bit shy and sincere.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:有一点有 还有一点真诚
Jake: Yeah, a bit shy and sincere.